ganzen in ordnung bringen zugleich hat
die coma pandemie uns bitter vor augen
geführt wie oft handlungsunfähig und
dysfunktional unser gemeinwesen geworden
ist aus dem organisations weltmeister
und der deutschen gründlichkeit ist
leider ein träges bürokratie monster
geworden auch in der wirtschaft ist
unser unsere wettbewerbsfähigkeit
deutlich zurückgegangen
die reform dividende der agenda 2010 ist
nun im jahr 2021 endgültig verbrauchten
auch der wohlstands puffer der
vergangenen jahrzehnte durch viele gut
ausgebildete fachkräfte und kluge
patente dieser wohlstands puffer ist
zurückgegangen für uns ist deshalb klar
so wie es ist kann es nicht bleiben
die bundestagswahl wird eine
richtungswahl sein wie geben wir dem
land die richtige richtung
aus dem status quo die einen setzen auf
die fortsetzung der staats frömmigkeit
wir setzen dagegen vertrauen in jede
einzelne und jeden einzelnen
die einen wollen noch mehr
staatseinfluss auf wirtschaft und
gesellschaft sie wollen lenken steuern
subventionieren und verbieten wir
hingegen vertrauen den menschen in
wirtschaft und gesellschaft und wollen
in gute rahmenbedingungen ersetzen
wir wollen sie entlasten von
finanzieller überforderung wir wollen
sie entfesseln von bürokratischen
stricken
wir wollen investieren in die
modernisierung von staat und
infrastruktur damit die menschen im
täglichen miteinander die zukünftige
richtung unserer gesellschaft ausprägen
können wir wollen meine damen und herren
insbesondere die quellen unseres
wohlstands neu gründen die
schlüsselindustrie
die gegenwärtig beschäftigung wohlstand
sozialer sicherheit und wachstum sichern
sind 100 jahre und älter wenn ich an den
maschinen den fahrzeugbau und die chemie
denken und zugleich sind sie unter einer
besonderen krisensituationen sind sie in
einer besonderen krisensituation durch
die korona pandemie und deshalb brauchen
wir unmittelbar nach der nächsten
bundestagswahl ein sofortprogramm raus
aus der krise mit einem moratorium für
zusätzliche belastungen in finanzieller
wie in bürokratischer hinsicht mit
sofort wirksamen entlastungen im
steuerlichen bereich beispielsweise die
von uns so vorgeschlagene negative
gewinn steuer also die verrechnung
aktueller pandemie bedingte verluste in
der steuer- mit früheren gewinnen bei
der steuer und eine entfesselung
offensive mit der wii ohne das ist ein
cent für den staat kostet 100 bürokratie
hürden abschaffen wollen und dann wird
es darum gehen durch die pandemie
durchzuschauen ihnen die zukunft und
erfolgsgeschichten wie bei und tech zu
schreiben und dafür brauchen
gründerinnen und gründer all diejenigen
die zukunft zu arbeitsplätzen
technologien schaffen wollen zuversicht
forschergeist sie brauchen die offenheit
des staates für alle technologien statt
der einseitigen bevorzugung von wenigen
unser staatswesen meine damen und herren
ist leider ein sanierungsfall geworden
deutschland ist im prinzip ein starkes
land mit menschen die viel potenzial
haben die zeigen wollen was in ihnen
steckt aber unser staatliches
gemeinwesen ist leider ein
sanierungsfall
es ist nicht hinreichend digital es ist
selbst gefesselt durch die eigenen
regeln
das zum beispiel beim digital packt die
zur verfügung stehenden gelder des
bundes gar nicht in den schulen ankommen
und seine sicherung
die sicherungssysteme dieses staatlichen
gemeinwesen sind nicht mehr auf der höhe
der zeit und nicht angepasst eine an
eine veränderte und insbesondere
alternde gesellschaft und besser wird
die große aufgabe des nächsten
jahrzehntes sein unseren staat zu
modernisieren ihn zu digitalisieren und
seine sicherungssysteme an die
veränderten flexibilitäts erwartungen
der menschen an das gestiegene bedürfnis
nach selbstbestimmung anzupassen und die
konsequenz aus der alterung der
gesellschaft zu ziehen indem wir über
die jetzt umlagefinanzierten systemen
hinaus auch stärker möglichkeiten der
eigenvorsorge der eigentumsbildung
möglichkeiten des kapitalmarkts nutzen
unser programm das ist mein
abschließender gedanke unser programm
enthält zahlreiche einzelne projekte und
ich bin doktor volker wissing unserem
generalsekretär und der
programmkommission sehr dankbar dass es
gelungen ist ein sehr prägnantes
ambitioniertes aber auch realistisches
programm vorzulegen es liest sich gut
und es ist geeignet vom programm papier
unmittelbar dann auch im gesetzestext
übertragen zu werden das wäre wert dass
man isst nicht nur als wahlprogramm
liest sondern das ist auch teil des
gesetzbuches das gesetz blattes wird
also ein sehr gutes programm mit vielen
einzelforderungen aber für uns und für
mich entscheidend ist dass dieses
programm von einem geist getragen ist
es ist der geist unserer liberalen
lebensauffassung es ist der geist der
liberalität
wir sind in einer zeit nicht nur durch
die pandemie aber durch sie verstärken
an der zeit wo immer mehr auf den staat
gesetzt wird wo der staat immer größer
wird der staat immer stärker in das
leben der menschen eingreift dem start
alles mögliche zugetraut wird obwohl die
bilanz seines handelns leider oft
noch verbesserungswürdig ist wir haben
einen gegen impuls mit diesem programm
vorgelegt als einzige der im parlament
vertretenen parteien wollen wir nicht
immer nur den staat stark machen sondern
jeder einzelne um jeden einzelnen nehmen
wir mehr verantwortung des bundes in der
bildung und zwar im gesamten der
gesamten biografie einfordern um die
menschen zu unterstützen indem wir ihnen
die piloten sessel des lebens
zurückgeben indem wir den staat zu einem
partner machen aber eben nicht zu einem
vormund der alles besser weiß und den
menschen den entscheidungsspielraum
einengt wir wollen die menschen stark
machen indem wir die wirtschaft
verordnen damit nicht einige wenige so
mächtig werden dass sie die regeln des
spiels bestimmen können wir wollen den
menschen dem freiraum lassen mit den
ergebnissen ihrer eigenen anstrengungen
und ihrer arbeit sich auch etwas
aufzubauen und wirtschaftlich voran zu
kommen
dieser geist von liberalität und
individualität es ist nicht nur dass
menschen freundlichste programm weil wir
den größten optimismus haben dass alle
menschen im prinzip
verantwortungsbewusst und vernünftig
sind und man ihnen deshalb entscheidung
und zutrauen kann
es ist nicht nur dass menschen
freundlichste programm es ist das
gegenprogramm zu all dem was die anderen
parteien vor allen dingen auf den staat
projizieren wollen deshalb sind wir
bereit zur übernahme von verantwortung
um diesen geist und unsere konkreten
projekte eben nicht nur in der
opposition vorzutragen sondern auch in
regierungshandeln münden zu lassen
unser wahlziel ist die umsetzung unseres
wahlprogramms dafür wollen wir so stark
zweistellig werden dass es in unserem
land keine schwarz-grüne und keine grüne
rot rote mehrheit gibt unser ziel ist
dass deutschland weiter aus der mitte
regiert wird und dass es ein
erneuerungsprogramm unseres landes gibt
dem wir eine richtung geben wollen
nämlich jeden einzelnen menschen
stark zu machen ja ich will ergänzen wir
haben
schonungslos bilanz gezogen bilanz
gezogen über den zustand unseres landes
und die gegenwärtige pandemie hat uns
dabei auch viele augen geöffnet wie den
bürgerinnen und bürgern auch wir sind zu
dem ergebnis gekommen dass es nicht so
bleiben kann wie es ist und deswegen
haben wir viele beteiligt an diesem
programm prozess viele haben auch
mitgemacht und kluge und innovative
ideen mit eingebracht um ein mutiges
programm vorzulegen mit dem wir
deutschland in eine gute zukunft führen
wollen wir setzen dabei nicht nur auf
einen handlungsfähigen staat sondern
insbesondere auch auf die kraft die in
unseren bürgerinnen und bürgern steckt
in jedem einzelnen die kreativität der
vielen die innovationskraft und
natürlich auch die agilität der märkte
wir wollen das land werden das in uns
steckt und dazu müssen wir zunächst raus
aus der krise
wir müssen den auf hohe wettbewerb
international gewinnen die dinge
verändern sich durch neue technologien
aber auch die gegenwärtige pandemie
ordnet vieles in der welt neu dazu muss
deutschland modernisiert werden und es
müssen die herausforderungen des
jahrzehnts gelöst werden globale
herausforderungen aber auch ganz eigene
herausforderung unserer gesellschaft ich
nenne beispielhaft beispielhaft die
demografische entwicklung die
insbesondere für die bundesrepublik
deutschland eine enorme herausforderung
darstellt der wir uns mutig stellen
wollen
wir wollen auch die klima den
klimawandel bekämpfen mit innovativen
ansätzen und mit dem was wir für ganz
wertvoll halten und was wir für
überlegen halten im vergleich zu anderen
systemen der welt nämlich die
innovationskraft des marktes und die
andere als systeme des marktes wir
wollen das was unser land in der
vergangenheit schon einmal stark gemacht
hat jetzt nutzen zur lösung der probleme
unserer zeit
selbstverständlich haben wir uns auch
mit dem thema finanzen intensiv
beschäftigt das steuersystem ist das
nervensystem eines staates und uns geht
es dabei um eine neujustierung des
privaten und des staatlichen sektors
wer glaubt dass investitionen nur von
staatlicher seite von nöten sind der
übersieht was private investitionen in
unserer gesellschaft und für unsere
gesellschaft leisten können und für eine
freie freiheitliche partei für die
freien demokraten ist natürlich das
verhältnis der steuerbelastung zu dem
was die verfügbaren einkommen und auch
die verfügbaren investitionsmittel
angeht immer ein besonders sensibler
punkt deswegen bleiben wir bei unserer
klaren aussage wir wollen keine
verschiebung zulasten des privaten hin
zum staat sondern wir wollen im
gegenteil auch entlastung und weiter
thematisieren und in den mittelpunkt
unserer politik stellen wir haben
gesehen dass der staat nicht der
alleinige der alleinige handelnde sein
kann wenn es um darum geht große
lösungen für große probleme zu
entwickeln der impfstoff kristallen
darin angesprochen von biontech er ist
durch private investitionen entstanden
durch die risikobereitschaft durch die
agilität von personen und die davon
überzeugt waren dass es eine lösung
geben muss um eben beispielsweise auch
in der biotechnologie
durch die veränderung von mrsa neue
impfstoffe entwickeln zu können und das
beispiel zeigt eben dass wir auf
privater seite eben auch
investitionsanreize brauchen wir finden
uns damit im übrigen in einem sehr guten
austausch und dialog auch mit der
arbeitnehmerseite und fühlen uns hier
sehr gut verstanden denn für die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer haben
private investitionen natürlich einen
großen effekt sie sichern arbeitsplätze
und sie ermöglichen zukunftschancen auch
soziale sicherheit in unserer
gesellschaft
der dialog den wir auch mit
gewerkschaften gestartet haben zu diesen
themen ist äußerst gewinn
und für uns auch von besonderem wert
die lösung für die zukunftsprobleme
steht für freie demokraten immer im
engen zusammenhang mit bildung bildung
ist für uns ein bürgerrecht es ist aber
auch ein schlüssel zur lösung von
künftigen problemen unserer gesellschaft
deswegen muss die bazooka unseres landes
wieder die bildung sein wir wollen ein
prozent der mehrwertsteuereinnahmen
zusätzlich in bildung investieren das
ermöglicht zusätzliche investitionen von
zweieinhalb milliarden euro und wir
wollen auch mutig optimistisch und ohne
scheuklappen auch den föderalismus in
bildungsfragen überprüfen und auch ein
stück weit neu justieren wenn bessere
lösungen von allen gewollt sind sie aber
an rechtlichen oder an traditionen
rechtlichen hürden oder traditionen
scheitern dann ist es an der zeit dinge
zu verändern und sie zu modernisieren
wir haben vorschläge dazu auf den tisch
gelegt ja die infrastruktur sie ist ein
ganz wichtiger schlüssel um menschen
chancen zu eröffnen
deswegen brauchen wir kräftige
infrastruktur investitionsmittel zum
einen aber wir müssen auch dafür sorgen
dass die infrastrukturinvestitionen
wieder möglich werden indem wir
konsequent bürokratie abbauen
planungsverfahren beschleunigen
vielleicht aus einer bestimmten
perspektive gut gemeinte
planungsvorgaben die am ende
infrastrukturausbau nahezu unmöglich
machen helfen unserer gesellschaft nicht
im gegenteil sie schaden uns sehr die
modernisierung unseres landes sie ist
offensichtlich geworden
in einer zeit in der wir nicht mehr mit
papier und bleistift unsere probleme
lösen können sondern in der wir ganz
offensichtlich auf digitale technologien
stärker zurückgreifen müssen digital
first bedenken second ist seit längerer
zeit ein motto dem wir uns verschrieben
haben und deswegen wollen wir auch ein
offensives ein mutiges
modernisierungsprogramm im bereich der
digitalisierung angehen wir brauchen
hier zentrale zuständigkeiten in einer
künftigen bundesregierung mit einem
digital
ministerium und wir brauchen auch
fortschritte in der umsetzung nicht nur
in der öffentlichen verwaltung auch da
ist die digitalisierung notwendig das
gesundheitswesen beispielsweise aber wir
brauchen auch die notwendigen
investitionen in die digitale
infrastruktur und natürlich das hängt
wieder eng mit dem steuersystem zusammen
wir brauchen auch investitionsanreize um
unsere wirtschafts teilnehmerinnen und
wirtschafts teilnehmer in die lage zu
versetzen kräftig in die digitalen
technologien zu investieren industrie
4.0 ist die zukunft sie eröffnet neue
möglichkeiten neue chancen
wir haben in deutschland lange über
diese dinge diskutiert aber zu wenig und
zu langsam
investiert und gehandelt das wollen wir
ändern deutschland sollte eines der
modernsten länder wieder werden das
waren wir einmal und sind es
offensichtlich heute nicht mehr
die ökologische transformation sie kann
eine gefahr für die arbeitsplätze für
den sozialen zusammenhalt in unserer
gesellschaft sein sie kann aber auch
eine chance für unsere gesellschaft sein
sie kann zum wohlstand faktor werden und
die den klimaschutz durch ein striktes
co2 limit für alle sektoren effektiv zu
gestalten das haben wir uns in unserem
programm vorgenommen wir wollen anreize
für innovative klimaschutztechnologien
setzen
der klimaschutz muss nach unserer
überzeugung technologie offen gestaltet
werden und der klimaschutz muss unter
zuhilfenahme der agilität der effizienz
der märkte erfolgen
nichts ist besser schneller und
effektiver als die wettbewerbs anreize
der marktwirtschaft deutschland wirkt
als wirkt heute so als habe unser land
diese positiven erfahrungen die wir im
letzten jahrhundert mit der sozialen
marktwirtschaft gemacht haben ein stück
weit vergessen wir wollen die dinge aber
nicht nur in erinnerung rufen sondern
wir wollen die soziale marktwirtschaft
stärken und sie stärker nutzen denn
viele dinge die wir uns als gesellschaft
vorgenommen haben hängen in der trägheit
der staatlichen systeme fest wir wollen
beispielsweise für die energie
denn die marktwirtschaft und die anreize
der märkte stärker nutzen
auch für den klimawandel ich habe schon
darüber gesprochen und natürlich auch
für die transformation die für unsere
industrie eine große herausforderung
aber eben auch eine chance ist nur ein
freiheitlich demokratischer ein
wirtschaftlich starker und ein moderner
staat wird die großen herausforderungen
der zeit bewältigen
grundsätzlich gilt stärken wir die
kräfte der sozialen marktwirtschaft und
des freihandels bringen wir das
verhältnis von privat und staat wieder
in eine balance geben wir mittelstand
selbstständigen und start-ups mehr raum
für erfolg und um kreative lösungen zu
schaffen
mit unserem programm nie gab es mehr zu
tun zeigen wir freie demokraten dass wir
bereit sind verantwortung in unserem
land zu übernehmen
wir setzen mit diesem programm keine
anreize um farben farb- spekulationen zu
starten sondern wir geben unserer
überzeugung ausdruck und diese
überzeugung hat keine farbe wir wollen
in unserer gesellschaft uns einbringen
wir wollen sie gestalten mit einem wert
der uns einer der höchsten ist dem wert
der freiheit der uns vertrauen lässt in
die verantwortungsbereitschaft unserer
gesellschaft der uns optimistisch in die
zukunft blicken lässt und der uns den
anreiz gibt anmutiges programm
vorzulegen dass deutschland gut
gebrauchen kann wir haben die zukunft im
blick und das heute im griff dank volker
wissing wir würden die fragerunde jetzt
starten mit der ersten frage von herrn
rösler von der süddeutschen zeitung
ja hallo herr bisher hallo herlinde ich
würde sie gerne fragen nach den
kandidaten sowie bei einer anderen
partei union
mit ihm könnten sie denn aus ihrer sicht
mit herrn söder oder herrn laschet
zumindest teile der das programm ist
besser umsetzen und damit sie nicht nur
sagen sie wollen sich dabei einer
anderen parteien einmischen würde ich
auch konkret fragen was denen sie ja
gesagt haben alle anderen parteien sind
staatsgläubig werden sie handtaschen und
herren so dass vergleichen welche von
beiden halten sie denn zumindest für
weniger staatsgeld also mit armin
laschet arbeiten wir in
nordrhein-westfalen ja sehr erfolgreich
zusammen
herr laschet hat in der vergangenen zeit
ja viele hinweise gegeben dass er auch
ein modernisierungskonzept für nötig
hält
aber armin laschet profitiert in seinem
regierungshandeln in nordrhein-westfalen
fraglos auch von den liberalen akzenten
die ihnen sein koalitionspartner gibt
wenn herr laschet etwa spricht über
einen entfesselung impuls den er dem
land geben will dann haben sie gemerkt
herr postler dann ist das nicht nur der
gedanke sondern sogar das vokabular der
freien demokraten bei herrn söder wissen
wir nicht so genau weil er ja dazu neigt
auch unterschiedlichen vorstellungen in
seiner politischen arbeit raum zu geben
da haben mal die einen und mal die
anderen mehr gewicht
mal geht es um den asyl tourismus dann
geht es um bienen und dann geht es um
kohle maßnahmen und ausgangssperren also
da wissen wir noch nicht so genau
entscheidend wird sein wie sieht das
wahlprogramm der union aus dass der
grünen etwa kennen wir ja schon
und das was die spd vor hat ist
ebenfalls bekannt bei der union ist für
uns die spannendste frage
ist vielleicht der für sie auch
wichtigste satz bei der union ist für
uns nicht die spannende frage wer am
ende der kanzlerkandidat sein wird
sondern was der inhalt des programms
sein soll
so dann schaue ich in die runde ob es
weitere wortmeldungen gibt
geben sie uns gerne ein zeichen im chat
wenn sie eine frage stellen wollen wir
haben ulrich steinkohl von der dpa
ja also ich habe zwei fragen uns war das
eine ist anschließend an den kollegen in
brüssel
die cdu spricht jetzt auch gerne von
staatsmodernisierung haben sie
eigentlich den eindruck dass sie und die
cdu und der modernisierung des staates
dasselbe verstehen und die zweite frage
wäre sie betonen ja jetzt wieder sehr
stark die individualität weniger staat
mehr eigenverantwortung an der korona
krieg ist nicht gerade gemerkt so also
bei der privatisierung von
krankenhäusern bei der privatisierung
anderer staat zur vorsorge genau das das
falsche prinzip ist den anfang machen
darf herr steinkohle die privat
verantwortete entwicklung eines
impfstoffs bei bayern tag war sehr
erfolgreich segensreich gar für die
menschheit die vom staat organisiert der
impfung desselben gibt's noch
unverändert anders zur vervollkommnung
die niedergelassenen ärztinnen und ärzte
haben enorm schnell impfen können die
staatlich organisierten impfzentren
haben sich damit länger schwer getan
also ich kann zu sagen die die fixierung
auf die problemlösungsfähigkeit des
staates also auch vor dem hintergrund
der korona pandemie nicht erkennen
sondern glaube dass wir eine gute
balance haben müssen zeit lassen sie
mich das so sagen wir haben wir sind aus
der balance geraten der das
schwergewicht liegt zu stark beim start
wir sagen nicht dass wir nur privat
wollen aber wir wollen wieder eine gute
balance haben ein staat der in seinen
kernaufgaben erfolgreich ist
also gesundheitswesen infrastruktur
bildung verwaltung justiz sicherheit der
aber damit einen dienst erweist den
privaten damit sie ihre lebenspläne
verwirklichen können
die staatliche bilanz gegenwärtig in den
punkten bei der bildung beim auszahlung
der hilfen also bei der verwaltungs
frage die war nicht durchgehend so
erfolgreich dass wir schon zufrieden
sein könnten damit ich will vielleicht
ein paar satz ergänzen das ist in der
tat so stein gold dass der staat sich
selbst schwächt wenn er sich verzettelt
und sich mit immer mehr aufgaben befasst
mit denen er sich nicht befassen muss
und mit denen er sich auch nicht gut
befassen kann
die entwicklung von innovationen ist in
den händen des staates nicht wirklich
gut aufgehoben
und diese detailverliebtheit des staates
der sich heute bis in die ernährungs
fragen der bürgerinnen und bürger so
ziemlich mit jedem mit jeder privaten
angelegenheit im detail befasst versetzt
den start in einen zustand der
eingeschränkten handlungsfähigkeit
deswegen ist die konzentration auf die
kernaufgaben eine stärkung des staates
und es ist eine stärkung der gesamten
gesellschaft wenn wir die dinge unter
wettbewerbs und markt anreizen schneller
besser effizienter und auch günstiger
zur verfügung gestellt werden können
wenn wir diese dinge unter zuhilfenahme
unserer marktwirtschaftlichen
anreizsysteme eben auch bewältigen
und deswegen ist es in der tat keine
maßnahme oder unser vorschlag stärker
die die bürgerinnen und bürger ins spiel
zu bringen dann marktwirtschaft ins
spiel zu bringen ist ein vorschlag zur
stärkung der gesamten gesellschaft aber
auch zur stärkung des staates denn wenn
er sich auf seine kernaufgaben
konzentriert hat er genug zu tun und wir
haben einige fehler gemacht in den
letzten jahren unsere gesellschaft hat
die möglichkeiten der marktwirtschaft
nicht mehr voll genutzt und das ist ein
grund warum wir zurückgefallen sind und
das wollen wir wieder ändern
es geht um eine gute balance
um eine ausgewogene ausrichtung um ein
gutes zusammenspiel von staat und markt
das ist unser anliegen und dabei spielt
die wirtschaft eine große rolle aber
eben auch spielen die freiräume mit der
bürgerinnen und bürger eine große rolle
die wir natürlich mit unseren
freiheitlichen grundsätzen programmen
auch in den blick nehmen
das ist nochmal an die erste nachfahren
ja entschuldigung
die erste frage ob es ist ja die unter
modernisierung des staates dasselbe
verstehen also wenn man das
regierungshandeln der cdu sich
gegenwärtig anschaut ist von
modernisierung des staates ja nicht viel
zu sehen
wir sind natürlich gespannt mit welchen
vorschlägen die union in die
bundestagswahl gehen wird und dann kann
man diese frage beantworten aber
sicherlich ist das vertrauen das die
freien demokraten in die bürgerinnen und
bürger haben ausgeprägter als bei
anderen mitbewerberinnen und mitbewerber
so dann würden wir weiter gehen und als
nächstes ist frau marschall von der
rheinischen post an der reihe
jahrhundert ob wir meinen und
funktioniert mich würde interessieren
der klimaschutz den haben sie stark im
programm auch wo ist da aus ihrer sicht
die stärkste abgrenzung unterscheidung
zu den grünen
und wo gibt es aber auch
anknüpfungspunkte zu den grünen beim
klimaschutz im viel gibt es
anknüpfungspunkte an alle die vernünftig
sind dazu zählen ja auch die grünen
nämlich das 1,5 grad ziel zu erreichen
die pariser klimaziele zu erreichen also
im ziel einig im weg sehr
unterschiedlich die grünen nutzen den
klimaschutz für einen kompletten umbau
von wirtschaft und gesellschaft und sie
wissen auch genau welche technologien
und welche lebensweisen
sie unterstützen wollen und welche sie
beenden möchten wir hingegen setzen auf
ein zentrales instrument das instrument
heißt co2 limit wir wollen das
klimaschädliche emissionen begrenzt
werden aber durch welche technologie das
im einzelnen gelingt das wollen wir dem
marktwirtschaftlichen ideenwettbewerb
überlassen weil der ideenwettbewerb der
erfindergeist das unternehmertum die
besten methoden sind um mit knappen
gütern hier eben co2 umzugehen und wir
fühlen uns also wie soll ich sagen
als eine marktwirtschaftliche partei in
der verpflichtung
genau diesen hervorragenden
koordinierungs mechanismus des marktes
in den dienst einer menschheitsaufgabe
wie der klimaschutz darstellt zu stellen
dann würden wir noch mal zu der frage
von frau marschall kommen weil es da mit
dem ton leider schwierigkeiten gibt
würde ich die frage vorlesen sie
abgeschickt genau die frage ist zum
infektionsschutzgesetz und da würde frau
marshall gerne wissen
die länder müssen im bundesrat dem
infektionsschutzgesetz ja nicht
zustimmen warum müssen ist trotzdem
warum muss es trotzdem einigkeit mit den
ländern geben und eine zweite frage noch
zur verantwortungsgemeinschaft aber ich
glaube wir starten erst mal mit dem
infektionsschutzgesetz aus unserer sicht
wäre das infektionsschutzgesetz besser
auch zustimmungspflichtig im bundesrat
ausgestaltet worden es gibt eine reihe
von bestimmungen die darauf hindeuten
dass es nicht nur ein einspruchsgesetz
ist aber generell auch im sinne eines
guten miteinanders von bund und länder
wäre es sinnvoll gewesen es hätte ja
eine abstimmung gegeben
frau marshall im grunde werden jetzt die
nachteile des alten verfahrens mit neuen
nachteilen verbunden und deshalb
verstehen wir nicht das aus der
gescheiterten oster ruhe diese diese
konsequenz im verfahren gezogen worden
ist
seinerzeit gab es kurzfristig
vorbereitete bund länder runden mit
heißer nadel gestrickte vorlagen die er
nach langen sitzungen ohne beteiligung
des parlaments eingebracht worden sind
und das verfahren ist ersetzt worden
jetzt dadurch dass mit heißer nadel die
bundesregierung ein gesetz strikt das in
einem eilverfahren am liebsten ohne
anhörung von expertinnen und experten
durch das parlament peitschen will und
die länder werden überhaupt gar nicht
mehr zu rate gezogen vom verfahren her
hätten wir etwas anderes vorgeschlagen
nämlich das sehr kurzfristig das könnte
in dieser woche passieren die
bundeskanzlerin eine regierungserklärung
abgibt und sagt wie sie die lage sieht
und was sie empfiehlt das wird im
parlament debattiert und am ende kommen
dann bund und länder zusammen und
beraten gemeinsam wie das umgesetzt
werden kann
denn gesetzlich
regelungen und befugnisse haben ja
länder und landkreise bereits jetzt aber
teilweise aus guten gründen kommt man zu
anderen ergebnissen als jetzt die
bundesregierung wenn sogar der
landkreistag das jetzt nun keine
vorfeldorganisation der fdp von einem
misstrauensvotum spricht dann muss das
doch ernst genommen werden
ganz konkret die hunderter inzidenz ist
nicht geeignet um das pandemie geschehen
abzubilden
denn wenn an einer stelle ist ein
cluster ausbruch gibt also
beispielsweise in einem
fleischverarbeitenden betrieb wie wir
das schon hatten viele neue infektionen
dazu kommen dann wird bei den jetzigen
bundesgesetz die konsequenz sein dass
wegen des ausbruchs an einer stelle den
man kennt und der kontrollierbar ist
teilweise dutzende kilometer entfernt
die landkreise sind ja groß auch
geimpfte menschen vom abendspaziergang
abgehalten werden das ist in sich
genommen keine kluge gesetzgebung sie
dient nämlich nicht im infektionsschutz
und auf der anderen seite
unverhältnismäßig die ausgangssperre als
solche sehen wir kritisch und die
notwendigkeit auch über test basiertes
öffnen in modellprojekten erfahrungen
erkenntnisse zu sammeln wird durch den
jetzt vorliegenden gesetzentwurf leider
vereitelt um es klar allerdings auch zu
sagen frau marsha handlung tut jetzt not
angesichts der steigenden
infektionszahlen und der
besorgniserregenden situation in der
intensivmedizin ist nichtstun keine
alternative aber jetzt wäre nötig auf
ebene der länder und landkreise gezielt
dort einzuschreiten wo das pandemie
geschehen sich verschärft die kontakt
beschränkungen der privaten haushalte
einzuschränken oder beziehungsweise die
zahl der kontakte weiter zu reduzieren
das testen stark auszudehnen beim impfen
zu beschleunigen indem alle jetzt
verfügbaren im free surfen auch verimpft
werden der zeitpunkt zwischen erst und
zweitens zeitlich gestreckt wird der
niedergelassene bereich
der medizin voll mit einbezogen wird
solche maßnahmen
die sind jetzt erforderlich und werden
von uns auch unterstützt auch in unseren
regierungsbeteiligungen in den ländern
diese bundes notbremse hingegen ist aus
vielerlei gründen länder und landkreise
werden nicht beteiligt kritik wird nicht
gehört hunderter inzidenz ausgangssperre
keine modellprojekte und
rechtsverordnungen die das parlament
zwar billigen muss aber mit einer
genehmigungs fiktion die dazu führt dass
echte beratung kaum je stattfinden wird
nach meiner erwartung dieses
bundesgesetz jedenfalls hätte man nicht
gebraucht entschuldigung das jetzt etwas
länger war aber ich denke das hat andere
auch nochmal aktuell interessiert
wir haben auch gleich noch eine zweite
frage von frau marshall und zwar geht es
darum die verantwortungsgemeinschaft die
frage lautet welche
steuererleichterungen können die partner
erwarten wir haben frau marschall
insgesamt für alle gruppen
steuererleichterungen vorgesehen weil
wir der meinung sind dass wir für in der
gesellschaft verantwortung gar nicht
hoch genug einschätzen können und
natürlich gilt das auch für die
verantwortungsgemeinschaft dort wo
menschen füreinander einstehen
dort leisten sie einen wertvollen
beitrag auch für das gemeinwesen und vor
dem hintergrund wollen wir natürlich
auch dort steuerlich entsprechend
honorieren wenn menschen sich
verantwortungsvoll verhalten und das ist
das was wir durchweg in unserem programm
im steuerbereich vorgesehen haben auch
für die verantwortungsgemeinschaft dann
haben wir die nächste frage von herrn
schmidt von der ard und stehen für die
zeitung ich habe eine frage in sachen
wirtschaft start-ups und mittelstand
habe ich bei ihnen herr wissing gehört
ob sie dann auf den satz nach schieben
könnten sie sich genau vorstellen ich
habe auch bei ihnen herr lindner eben
gehört nochmal das mit den negativen
gewinnsteuer also vereinfacht
ausgedrückt dass bei unternehmen die
chance gibt durch steuerliche
verrechnung von verlusten besser durch
diese phase der aktuellen krise zu
kommen und wenn sich noch eine zweite
frage gestattet
an einem von ihnen beiden bei den grünen
ich habe hinter regalen mit lehne es ab
september in regierungen gehen könnte
daran beide male grünen drei also ich
fand es interessant dass sie gesagt
haben wir möchten kein schwarz-grün
gerechten kein grün rot rot wir sind
sozusagen als angebot gerne dabei wo
könnte es da noch knacken wo könnte es
möglicherweise nicht leicht werden das
zu erfüllen ja ich mit zum thema
besteuerung start ups im mittelstand und
negative gewinn steuer ist ganz klar wir
haben in deutschland die situation das
risikokapital nach wie vor nicht in
ausreichendem maße in unser land findet
wir haben das problem dass wir generell
gewinne und verluste nicht gleich
behandeln im steuerrecht wir müssen
etwas tun an der breite der
bemessungsgrundlage es muss klar sein
dass in deutschland für jeden der
investiert kosten nicht steuerpflichtig
sind das ist heute leider nicht mehr so
klar und wir brauchen natürlich eine
mittelstandsfreundliche steuersystem
deswegen halten wir auch an einer
einkommenssteuerreform fest der
einkommenssteuertarif ist ja nicht nur
der steuertarif von arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmern sondern eben auch der
unternehmenssteuer tarif des deutschen
mittelstandes der sehr stark ist der
aber auch extrem im internationalen
wettbewerb steht und hierzu nehmen sich
steuerwettbewerbs nachteilen ausgesetzt
sieht und zur negativen gewinnsteuern um
das klar zu sagen das ist der einzige
weg den der staat wirklich bewältigen
kann wir haben gegenwärtig von herrn
altmaier 10 wirtschafts hilfsprogramme
die parallel laufen die auch in der
ausgestaltung nicht als gerecht
empfunden werden und die von der
administration ja alle überfordern
vor allen dingen ihn selbst und deswegen
wäre der vorschlag den wir gemacht haben
mit einer negativen gewinnsteuern einer
solchen situation
zu reagieren deutlich besser vor allen
dingen weil er weil die negative
gewinnsteuern ohne dass der staat eine
aufwendige prüfung vornehmen muss
differenziert zwischen unternehmen mit
einem funktionierenden geschäftsmodell
und solchen deren geschäftsmodell am
markt eher weniger erfolgreich ist und
diese differenzierung die ist notwendig
wenn man die auswirkungen staatlicher
hilfsprogramme auf die marktwirtschaft
und des wettbewerbs system so gering wie
möglich halten möchte
das muss eigentlich ein
wirtschaftsminister verstehen und er
muss das im grunde genommen auch zum
ziel seiner hilfsprogramme machen das
findet gegenwärtig leider nicht statt
und weil wir sagen wir müssen auch für
künftige krisen natürlich uns wappnen
es weiß ja kein mensch wie lange diese
pandemie dauert und mit welchen
herausforderungen wir künftig
konfrontiert sind brauchen wir hier
dringend ein anderes system
und natürlich ist die negative
gewinnsteuern passgenau ein puzzleteil
auch zu unserem programm das da lautet
die marktwirtschaft stärker nutzen
das wettbewerbssystem pflegen und nicht
durch staatliche interventionen
schwächen und vor allen dingen eben ich
habe es vorhin erwähnt den staat nicht
sich überheben lassen sich nicht
verzetteln mit programmen die er selbst
nicht bewältigen kann und vor dem
hintergrund bedauern wir sehr dass
dieser vorschlag der ja sehr früh von
uns schon vorgebracht worden ist nicht
aufgegriffen wurde
jetzt gab es einen kleinen bereich wo
die bundesregierung das gemacht hat aber
der das zentrale instrument der
staatlichen wirtschaftshilfen ist leider
nicht über dieses instrument gegangen
und das wäre wesentlich besser gewesen
herr schmidt können sie ihre erste frage
noch kurz etwas etwas präzisieren da
ging es um koalitionsverhandlungen und
die zweite frage war das
koalitionsverhandlungen grünen das hatte
ich aufgenommen
worauf wollte sie genau hinaus ja gerne
ich habe mir notiert als sie eben sagten
dass im grunde also ich fass es mal in
baden worten zusammen wir möchten
eigentlich kein schwarz grünen möchten
eigentlich kein grün rot rot das heißt
wie er die fdp
dass ihr offen sind für
regierungsbildungen auf bundesebene ende
september und eine einfache frage oder
ja populäre frage wäre wo kannst
knirscht bei in beiden modellen deren
die grünen da hab ich jetzt hat ja ganz
bewusst beim klimaschutz
einfach fragen wo möglicherweise noch
ich kann und will koalitionsgespräche
natürlich jetzt nicht vorwegnehmen dafür
haben sie verständnis
es muss insgesamt ein tragfähiges
regierungsprogramm herauskommen damit
die fdp eine koalition eintritt und da
gibt es punkte
da muss die eine seite nach geben es
gibt punkte da wird die andere seite
nachgeben müssen es müssen sie am ende
alle respektiert sehen mit ihren
projekten und anliegen und es muss den
geist eines fairen miteinanders geben
und dann können koalitionen klappen
klar ist dass für uns steuererhöhungen
ausgeschlossen sind
da kann ich eine politische garantie
abgeben herr schmidt mit der fdp wird es
keine höheren belastungen bei den
einkommen der beschäftigten oder bei
denjenigen geben die verantwortung für
arbeitsplätze in unserem land tragen
seine politische garantie man kann
darüber diskutieren ob man die menschen
unterschiedlich stark entlastet aber wir
kennen niemanden in diesem land der zu
wenig steuern zahlt mit ausnahme
vielleicht von google facebook und apple
wo wir gerne noch einen zusätzlichen
finanzierungsbeitrag für unser
gemeinwesen einholen wollen danke ihnen
frage übergehen dann kommt von herrn
jahren von der ard an herrn wisse ja
vielen dank das skript eigentlich an das
eben gesagte doch auch an
wissing sie regiert in rheinland pfalz
aus ihrer sicht erfolgreich auch mit der
spd
aber wenn ich jetzt auf der
das eben gesagte keine keine höhere
steuerbelastung für mich geforderte auf
die b wie bewerten sie denn die chancen
dass mit aller spd im bund hin zu
bekommen also wir setzen doch auch
steuererhöhungen wieder regieren in der
tat in rheinland pfalz erfolgreich dass
sie nicht nur ich so das haben die
wählerinnen und wähler so gesehen die
haben die regierung gerade bei der
landtagswahl bestätigt ich bin der
festen überzeugung dass wir gute
argumente haben für unser steuer
politisches programm und insofern setzen
wir auf die kraft unserer argumente und
wir sind bereit über unsere inhalte mit
partnern zu sprechen gegenwärtig
vermutlich eine koalition mit
sozialdemokraten und grünen in
rheinland-pfalz oder wir arbeiten jetzt
hat einigen wochen daran
und natürlich spielen die inhalte die
wir in dieser koalition einbringen
können eine ganz zentrale rolle das ist
auf landesebene etwas anders als auf
bundesebene und wir haben auch nicht
übersehen dass die spd steuern erhöhen
möchte aber das ist deren vorschlag und
die wählerinnen und wähler müssen
darüber entscheiden ob sie sich eine
höhere belastung wünschen ob sie glauben
dass eine schwächung der
investitionsmöglichkeiten der deutschen
wirtschaft hilfreich ist um das land in
die zukunft zu führen oder ob das
angebot der freien demokraten
vielleicht attraktiver sein kann die
wirtschaft jetzt neben dem staat auch in
die lage zu versetzen zu investieren um
innovationen hervorzubringen
wir haben gute argumente und wir
vertrauen darauf dass wir partner finden
nach der bundestagswahl die wir von
unseren argumenten überzeugen können
wer mit uns dann am ende ins gespräch
kommt das entscheiden die wählerinnen
und wähler dann haben wir als nächsten
herrn rats von reuters hallo hallo
hallo hören wir sind ein verein zum
thema impfen würde mich interessieren
wahrscheinlich herr lindner ist nach wie
vor für sinnvoll halten an der
priorisierung festzuhalten jetzt wo die
hausärzte jetzt nimmt auch eingebunden
sind und noch eine zweite frage
inwieweit halten sie es dann auch für
sinnvoll dass geimpft dann entsprechend
mehr freiheiten genießen im öffentlichen
leben also was das impfen angeht halte
ich das für sehr sinnvoll an der an der
einbeziehung der privaten arztpraxis
festzuhalten weil wir dort natürlich ein
know how vorfinden und eine eine
organisationsstruktur die sehr
unkompliziert sehr einfach und sehr
schnell ist es ist im übrigen auch für
die bürgerinnen und bürger viel
angenehmer an impftermin mit der der den
vertrauten arzt vor ort zu machen als
staatliche impfzentren aufzusuchen
das ist eine zusätzliche belastung für
die menschen die nicht notwendig ist und
die ärztinnen und ärzte kennen ihre
patienten auch sehr gut und können gut
beurteilen wie sie auf eine impfung
reagieren und wie auch eine impfung
sinnvoller weise durchgeführt wird ich
glaube dass das die agilität hier auch
der privaten arztpraxen einen schaden
der vorteil ist und bin nicht davon
überzeugt dass diese impfzentren einen
mehrwert für uns bringen die noch um die
priorisierung der reihenfolge noch und
auch was die reihenfolge angeht sind
ärzte die ihre patienten gut kennen
durchaus in der lage einen wertvollen
beitrag zu leisten
das heißt aber für easy rung dann schon
lockern aufheben oder erst mal daran
dass kroatisch gestalten herz also wenn
beispielsweise termine in einer praxis
kurzfristig am spätnachmittag abgesagt
werden
dann muss es doch möglich sein auch
außerhalb der prioritäten folge dafür zu
sorgen dass diese impfdosis auch genutzt
werden kann
etwas mehr pragmatismus tut uns da gut
und wenn ich es richtig im ohr habe wird
das ja auch von seiten der
ministerpräsidenten dringend angemahnt
und
und vorgeschlagen bitte helfen sie mir
noch einmal auf die sprünge hat sie
hatten auch ein zweiter aspekt den sie
angefragt hatten nach der priorisierung
ja wie arri frage der grundrechte bei
geimpften das ist für uns völlig klar
wenn wie es jetzt ja wissenschaftliche
evidenz gibt von menschen keine gefahr
mehr ausgeht nach einer impfung und
einer sich anschließenden wartezeit dann
sind freiheits einschränkungen
grundrechts einschränkungen nicht mehr
gerechtfertigt wenige ausnahmen gibt es
wie zum beispiel eine maske pflicht im
öffentlichen raum weil es schlicht nicht
kontrollierbar wäre wegen des tragens
und nicht tragen zu einer maske immer
die menschen zu befragen nach ihren
impfstatus darüber hinaus halten der
freiheits einschränkungen dabei aber
nicht mehr auf dauer für für
verfassungsrechtlich vertretbar ein
grund warum wir ja auch die bundes
notbremse so kritisch sehen denn wie ich
eingangs schon sagte die vorstellung
dass geimpfte paare die angehörigen
eines haushalts die sind geimpft und die
wollen ein abendspaziergang machen dass
das bei einer 100er incidents bereits
untersagt wird ist in doppelter hinsicht
verfassungsrechtlich aus unserer sicht
problematisch und ich sage voraus da
wird es auch prüfungen in karlsruhe
geben
hat dir der der zentrale punkt ist dabei
dass grundrechte individuelle
freiheitsrechte sind die nicht unter dem
vorbehalt kollektiver gleichheit stehen
der staat muss gegenüber jedem einzelnen
bürger einen grund haben grundrechte zu
beschränken und der grund kann nicht
lauten weil ich dem einen die
grundrechte einschränken muss muss für
den anderen das gleiche gelten das ist
eben bei individuellen freiheitsrechten
nicht der fall
das grundgesetz für die bundesrepublik
deutschland ist an dieser stelle klar
und wir in unserer aussage ebenso so ich
sehe keine weiteren fragen im chat mehr
und damit möchten wir uns ganz herzlich
für ihre teilnahme und führen tragen
bedanken und wünschen ihnen einen
schönen tag vielen lang auf wiedersehen
tschüs